Every TV show has to come to an end eventually.
Some end of the creators' own accord.
Even more are canceled by the network that
airs them.
Here are some of the saddest reasons ever
that TV shows were forced to end their runs.
COVID-19 put a nearly uniform stop to most
of show business, along with the rest of the
world.
Almost every TV and movie production came
to a screeching halt.
Many projects got pushed back, and at least
one was canceled mid-production: Netflix wrestling
dramedy "GLOW."
Even though it had several unresolved storylines,
the show was canceled because of the unique
difficulties it presented.
"GLOW" was three weeks into filming its fourth
season when the world changed in March 2020.
Netflix spent the next seven months trying
to find a safe way to restart production,
but the particular circumstances were too
difficult to overcome.
The show was shot in Los Angeles, a COVID
hotspot in and of itself.
Even worse, the show's core was wrestling
— an activity that requires physical contact
and heavy breathing in close quarters.
Combine all this with the show being a high
budget ensemble piece with about 20 principal
cast members, and Netflix just couldn't find
a way to make it work safely.
Deadline broke the inevitable news on October
5, 2020: Netflix had canceled "GLOW."
Series creators Liz Flahive and Carly Mensch
shared,
"COVID has killed actual humans.
It's a national tragedy and should be our
focus.
COVID also apparently took down our show."
Thankfully, there are no reports of anyone
involved in the production catching COVID,
and all the series regulars were paid in full.
The cast has since expressed interest in a
feature length movie to wrap up the story.
Robert Schimmel's life was more tragedy than
comedy, up to and including his 2010 death
in a car accident.
One such tragedy was the story surrounding
his planned sitcom, "Schimmel" — and how
it never got past the pilot.
In 1999, Schimmel signed on to do a sitcom
with 20th Century Fox.
Mike Scully, executive producer of "The Simpsons,"
was set to have a hand in it.
A pilot was shot — in which a very young
Brie Larson played his daughter — and got
picked up by the Fox network in 2000.
Mere days after the announcement, however,
Schimmel was diagnosed with non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma and given six months to live.
Production on his sitcom stopped while he
went into treatment, and he managed to make
a full recovery.
Variety reported in January 2001 that production
was intended to resume, but the network axed
it after the schedule got a little too crowded.
The pilot's cold open surfaced on YouTube
in 2006 and Schimmel posted some outtakes
to his Facebook page in August 2010.
"Friend Me," announced in early 2012, was
to follow two friends who moved from Indiana
to Los Angeles to work at Groupon.
How they ended up with that show title for
characters in that line of work remains a
mystery.
Attached to star was Christopher Mintz-Plasse.
Yeah, McLovin.
“I am McLovin.”
Also attached was Nicholas Braun.
He would insist on venturing out into their
new city while the other would remain a homebody
trying to keep his Midwest roots.
Unfortunately, due to real life tragedy, it
never made it to air.
"Friend Me" was co-created by Alan Kirschenbaum,
a veteran TV writer who was best known as
the creator of "Yes, Dear."
In October 2012, Kirschenbaum was found dead
in his home of a suspected suicide.
This, among many other things, put the show
— which had yet to debut — in a state
of limbo.
After months of delays and uncertainty, then-CBS
President Les Moonves confirmed at an August
2013 TCA press event that there were no plans
to show or burn off the episodes.
As such, the show remains unaired to this
day.
Few "Doctor Who" spinoffs were more enduring
than "The Sarah Jane Adventures."
Investigative journalist Sarah Jane Smith,
played by Elisabeth Sladen, was one of the
longest tenured characters on television.
This made all the more impressive that she
came from a series marked entirely by change.
"The Sarah Jane Adventures" was aimed at a
young audience and followed Sarah Jane on
her investigative alien journeys.
“I saw amazing things out there in space.”
The show was a huge hit, and it was stopped
by the only thing that could have stopped
it: Sladen's death.
Producer Brian Minchin told Doctor Who Magazine
in 2016 that the BBC loved the show and expected
to get more seasons after the current one
wrapped.
Then in early 2011, Sladen called producer
Russell T. Davies and informed him that she
had cancer and didn't have long to live.
The crew, over 100 people, kept it secret.
Between the death of their star and the ensuing
heartbreak, all parties involved decided to
regretfully end the show.
Minchin did have a curious note, though:
"Russell emailed me not so long ago saying,
'We shouldn't have stopped, should we?'
He thinks we canceled the show out of shock.
And he's right.
It was such a lovely show, and Lis was fantastic."
On April 19, 2020, the nine-year anniversary
of her death, Davies put together a final
episode: "Farewell, Sarah Jane," which depicted
a memorial service for the title character.
"Grace Under Fire" was one of the first big
hits from TV megaproducer Chuck Lorre.
The show starred Brett Butler as Grace, a
single mother raising her kids after a divorce.
Grace was a recovering alcoholic, while Butler
herself was anything but recovered.
This caused problems for her and everyone
around her, which ultimately ended the show.
Butler became infamous for her volatile backstage
behavior, with a bad temperament and a drug
addiction that kept feeding off each other.
She was known for berating her coworkers,
which led to five executive producers over
a mere five years and the departure of two
cast members.
Entertainment Weekly reported that the low
point was "Vega$," a crossover event with
other popular sitcoms.
Production teams for the other shows were
mortified by her behavior, which often delayed
production.
On top of her erratic behavior were her trips
to rehab for painkiller addiction.
Each visit stopped production, dropped ratings,
and just added to the frustration.
One of these trips was partway through Season
5.
Unable to handle Butler's erratic behavior
anymore, ABC shut down the show.
According to the Orlando Sentinel, the production
company claimed,
"We have decided to suspend production [...] so
that Brett may have time to resolve some personal
issues."
Production never resumed.
"Megan Wants A Millionaire" was one of about
a billion D-list celebrity dating shows from
the late 2000s.
It starred former "Rock of Love" contestant
Megan Hauserman, who had a bunch of millionaires
compete to make her a trophy wife.
But the show got canceled before the end of
the first season after one of the contestants
killed himself and someone else.
The contestant in question was real estate
investor Ryan Jenkins.
The entire series was in the can by the time
he committed his crime, so we know he came
in third.
Not long after he wrapped his part in the
series, he married a woman named Jasmine Fiore,
only for the two to later separate.
Jenkins joined the cast of "I Love Money"
season 3.
Fiore's body, which the New York Times described
as "mutilated," was found in late April 2009,
and Jenkins fled to Canada after getting charged
with killing her.
VH1 promptly canceled "Megan Wants A Millionaire"
and left the last few episodes unaired.
Jenkins was later found dead in a motel in
Hope, British Columbia, of an apparent suicide.
"I Love Money" season 3 was also preemptively
pulled, never airing an episode.
"Ellen" was a hit sitcom in its time, but
it will always be remembered for one thing:
"The Puppy Episode."
It saw the main character Ellen, played by
Ellen DeGeneres, come out of the closet — not
long after DeGeneres herself did in real life.
"The Puppy Episode" drew monster ratings and
got massive publicity, but it also marked
the beginning of the end for the show.
Going forward, DeGeneres and ABC clashed behind
the scenes.
The New York Times reported that ABC tried
to limit the number of LGBTQ storylines and
even at one time slapped a special viewer's
advisory in front of the show.
DeGeneres was quick to point out that shows
about heterosexual relationships had no such
warning.
GLAAD media director Chaz Bono noted to Variety
the dangers in the show becoming, quote, "too
LGBTQ,” especially after it became important
to the plots.
He said,
"This is network prime time.
When a show treats gay issues over and over
again, it becomes 'a gay show,' and the average
viewer says, 'Hey, I'm not gay — I'm not
going to watch it.'"
The show's ratings declined, and it's certainly
possible that the audience and networks weren't
quite ready.
If the show's cancellation wasn't proof enough
of this, the hit that Laura Dern's career
took was.
Dern, whose character made Ellen realize that
she was gay, started getting death threats.
Dern hit a career peak with "Jurassic Park,"
but the backlash to "The Puppy Episode" meant
that she stopped getting offered roles for
a significant period of time.
In 2017, CBS aired a sequel series to the
classic Denzel Washington film "Training Day."
The show was clearly meant to be a major cornerstone
for the network.
The production team included Antoine Fuqua,
the director of the movie, and producer Jerry
Bruckheimer, and had a legit star in Bill
Paxton.
Nonetheless, the show only garnered modest
ratings — not exactly a smash hit.
Then the show hit a bigger issue.
After four episodes aired, Bill Paxton died
at the age of 61.
All 13 episodes were in the can at the time,
so production wasn't impeded, but that was
a small consolation given the sudden death
of the well-liked star.
Many sources, including Deadline, predicted
that Paxton's death guaranteed the show wouldn't
get another season.
This proved accurate: there was a small uptick
in ratings after his death before they tanked.
"Training Day" already had a weak path forward,
one that turned impossible without Paxton.
The Duggar family — all 19 kids and counting
— made TLC a lot of money over the course
of two shows.
Both of these shows ended due to abrupt and
upsetting circumstances.
The first show, "19 Kids and Counting," ran
on the network from 2008 to 2015.
Viewers got to know the Duggar family, devout
Baptists who didn't use birth control and
ended up with a massive, religious, homeschooled
clan.
The show ended abruptly after it was revealed
that Josh Duggar, one of the sons, molested
five girls over several years — made more
sickening by the fact that four of them were
his own sisters.
TLC went to the well again with the spinoff
"Counting On."
This show, which ran from 2015 to 2020, originally
followed some of the older Duggar siblings
before roping in the rest of the family.
This, too, was canceled due to Josh Duggar.
As if his previous actions weren't disgusting
enough, he now faces federal charges for receiving
and possessing child sexually abusive material.
Even though he wasn't part of the show, the
name and the publicity was too much for all
involved — especially the network — to
deal with in public.
"The Jeremy Kyle Show" was one of the longest-running
tabloid talk shows in the UK.
For those unfamiliar, take a minute to imagine
"The Jerry Springer Show" for a class of people
who call French fries "chips."
In typical tabloid talk fashion, things often
got controversial, violent, and embarrassing.
A popular tool on the show was a lie detector,
and it was one such segment that led to the
show finally getting canceled.
During the first week of May 2019, a man named
Steve Dymond went on "The Jeremy Kyle Show"
to prove that he hadn't cheated on his ex-partner.
Dymond failed the lie detector test, and Kyle
mocked him.
Family and friends report that Dymond, who
was already diagnosed with depression and
on medication, was distressed and humiliated.
On May 9, Dymond was found dead in his home
of a morphine overdose, which many suspected
to be a suicide.
The ITV network put out a statement expressing
sympathies for Dymond's family and said,
"Given the gravity of recent events we have
decided to end production of 'The Jeremy Kyle
Show.'"
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline​ at​ 1-800-273-TALK
(8255)​.